what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to chad discovers wife as
an escort and the videos are wild before
i start don't forget to subscribe to the
channel bring that notification now that
we are going to be notified of my daily
videos all right let's let's get this
show on the road
i have never used
the first the first video
sergeant divorced his wife after
discovering wife was an escort
so a new york city spine surgeon dr ham
joe kim divorces former miss connecticut
regina turner claims she's been escorted
kim says he first discovered this when
scrolling through imessage and found the
text between regina and a man regarding
sexual favors in december of 2020. the
doctor claimed to have learned of his
wife's double life after they separated
becoming aware that she
has been exchanging sexual services for
receipts of money with multiple men
before as well as during the marriage
according to court filings
okay this is why the red pell exists
lady you had everything
he was good looking he was successful
like
what more did you need
she claims to have covered her secret
sex work by telling her husband that
she's spending time developing an app
and receiving venture capital funding
i mean they were definitely funding
something that wasn't your bank account
you feel me that was a bank account she
got a spur bank it was a bank
banks a bank and they donated let me let
me feel both banks isn't that crazy
man's a spine surgeon
so while he's over there fixing spine
she was getting her back broken
y'all man if this was broke back
mountain he'd be the asian guy not
getting any
no no bob you're
court documents also say that
she lied about her education she
supposedly been completing a chemistry
major at the university of connecticut
until she took a break to complete to
compete in the miss usa pageant
though the documents claim she never
even completed high school
hey what up sister and you know what i
can't even matter i'm a high school
dropout i'd be a big old hypocrite
if i said anything about her so
shout out to another high school dropout
finances bank subpoenas show that she
may have earned as close to seven
hundred miles
2015 to 2021
i have never used an online dating
service
the first
the thing is she's so believable
like i believe it she seems so innocent
[Music]
i bet you are the online dating service
you are tinder bumble you are
self-served wow
i've never used an online dating service
but back page is my [ __ ]
that's the clip that you're going to
pull up hold up
i didn't know i was going to start
that that's that's just questions that
they have to answer these pageants okay
yeah make it sound like they know some
[ __ ] i appreciate that she's very
concerned with what's being taught in
school
considering the fact that she's a high
school dropout
i would not feel comfortable in a
tastefully nude photo shoot
oh wow
here we go let's go
let's go she would have fooled me too
it's okay chad it's okay she would have
fooled me too i swear to god she
wouldn't really it's all about image bro
it's gonna get better let's go
put fresh play it's
nice this is nice yellow trolling this
is this is nice this is gold right there
this is gems
just yeah
you know listen photo shoots
gross
but hoenn
but you know that's the era of
respectability
yeah that's my dick
this is cringe
what the hell
[Music]
what the [ __ ] am i watching
i guarantee you the guys who work at
like these pageant shows are like
what what what dumb [ __ ] can we make
these models
motorboat because like you know it's
some ugly gremlin behind the camera
being like i have control
you know how much imagination i have
from dungeons and dragons
yo
hi could you please make noise just like
a cat for me
she went meow
okay okay okay
now now let me ask you a question
do your best impersonation of a dungeon
master
what's a dungeon master oh
she said
[Laughter]
yo that has to be your nastiest looking
character you ever hear yeah god damn
yeah every now and then when i'm
masturbating i use it
it still says cat yeah
maybe she thought that's the car that's
a cat purring or maybe she's just like
oh cat which cat did you mean because my
other one does a little
i'll do both for you meow and
everybody if you guys have ever heard
that noise in bed by accident it's
always followed by a
quietness and a sorry
[Laughter]
every time that i've been clapping you
clapping a girl from behind and
sometimes you pull out then you pull
back in and it makes them
girl and there's a quiet period the girl
goes
sorry
guys leave a comment and like below if
you guys have ever
heard sorry after
of course
our ladies if you said
you guys have to say don't worry about
it i'll do it again
that's how you know you grew up in
suburbia
so you know you grow
if that's your idea of what a police
siren is like that means you haven't
heard that [ __ ] yeah you don't know the
real thing
okay it was not funny guys i i don't i
don't want to be that [ __ ]
it wasn't that funny this nigga's hair
turns good sprinkles
because it's bathing and there's traffic
[Applause]
yo
rate that impression out of 10. that
[ __ ] was crazy that's a 12 [ __ ]
alright let's go
hi i'm regina miss connecticut and i'm
maxine's new ad exec you would think for
a big ass like company like maxim they
would get like some decent sound
equipment what the [ __ ] is that hissing
noise
sound or even look i see you
i could definitely see how she got all
that money
yeah i could definitely see it
well and she comes off as so innocent oh
my gosh you can't
i could not i can't i could definitely
see it i could see it yeah i might try
it i
you know it's good
i mean it's not my type either but i
like filling me on sometimes
yeah saute some mushrooms put on a plate
well i do work as an oral surgeon's
assistant when i'm not modeling
that's a decade-long troll this is you
can
what does kevin samuel say you can't
make this [ __ ] up
uh that's funny oral surgeon
oral assistant
dog doc
you need some
assistance with that sir got got
that
rubble rubble rubble yo son this is the
biggest puzzle i've ever seen i do some
office work when i'm not assisting any
surgery
didn't she just say i wouldn't be
comfortable in a nude photo shoot she is
way too comfortable you're in your
underwear
it's not that different
what the [ __ ] what did she say
you know what maybe it's because i
already know she's holding so everything
sounds like she's still holding yeah you
know what i mean
she was beholden back then
that sounds like it dr kim is trying to
avoid the marriage on the basis of fraud
saying school skills that's cool aka dr
kim's hoping not to lose all his money
to a [ __ ] who was basically fleecing
him for his money and lying about how
much money she made
good damn good for her damn
what you mean what's being good for her
look for her do you think
really
i don't think she's married to the man
and she's lying about the fact that
she's escorting fleece
is her game but good for her i mean
there's nothing else good for her
doesn't mean like oh good for you i'm
like good for you whatever just got
caught it's not so much i'm like i don't
wish her well whatever
this is
this is a gold digger extraordinaire
this is she got the bag from the dude
and she get another bag from the dude
and she's going to leave him so she can
go do whatever the [ __ ] she wants
she get the back she's not a gold digger
she can give a course on how to finesse
to be honest
she wants to make real money get on
youtube
and give your secrets on how to finesse
one
be really hot
i can't i can't lie and say that's not
step one platinum digger you feel me
like there's some people that like that
they like the last style they feel like
they like the lifestyle stuff yeah it's
gratification gratification people may
paying for the box for them that's their
[ __ ]
is i have a cousin that's like involved
in that stuff
and
she says that it like turns her on that
men are like actually willing to like
spend their money on her
i'm like oh god okay if they do not
she does not make seven hundred thousand
dollars a year though i'll tell you that
much like that yeah some women are
really like that there's there's like oh
i'm worth this it puts an amount on what
they're worth you know what i mean
it's it goes deep it really goes deep
but yeah
some people are like that you could be
she could be with a spine surgeon or
whatever with someone making a prince
from dubai she would still be hoeing
because that's that's her thing and you
know the money that he gives one thing
but being
being being wanted by other men is
another thing he is spine surgeon when
you lead with your money don't surprise
when she goes after a bigger fish
because at the end of the day you might
be a spine surgeon
but you ain't not a ceo of bank of
america you feel me there's always
somebody with more money than you so if
that's what you're leading with when you
attract her don't be surprised when she
go for more i don't think that's the
issue but carry on what do you mean
that's because i think that the issue is
what i said but keep on what do you mean
that some women just work yeah i think
she likes it i think she likes it the
monday he gives her doesn't gratify her
you understand what i'm saying but
whenever she go gets other bags like
that it gratifies oh people want her you
know i mean there's other people than
one person you know she's not for that
just one person what gratifies her was
give her gratification is other people
paying for a box so i don't think it's
like because other people are leading
with money or something like that it's
just the gratification that all this
money is giving to her well it's
addictive even when i talk to my cousin
about it like it's literally addictive
they get like a rush from getting money
for them their bodies
oddly enough quantifies her value it
doesn't matter because if he leads with
money and that's what he use if he leads
with money to attract women then that's
all they're going to be there for it
doesn't you're right you know what i'm
saying at the end of the day it's like
see it's hard though because do these
men have the time to lead with anything
else
like i almost feel like these men
just think it's like part of the process
because they're like well i can't lead
with anything else i got out of the time
working like
70 hours a week you might be about
whatever she is if that's what you're
offering are you're just giving her what
she wants yeah right and so at the end
of the day if that's what she came in
there for she has no lawyer i speak of
the devil my cousin's facetiming me
right now do i answer no no
nah what do you owe to the cash true
right
finance releases
so it's like you can buy the loyal
loyalty which is not really real so
that's that's the things it's a it's a
tough thing right because you see this
often you see it's often with people who
make a lot of money right because then
they think like all right now that i'm
making money the marriage and everything
is going to come along and everyone's
going to that's not the way it works
can't buy people's affection inherently
you can buy some let me refresh you can
buy their affection
buying their loyalty buying their
that's a different story that's a
different story and especially with the
confines of marriage where once they can
divorce you they can get the money out
of you
yeah you're gonna have a hard time
making that [ __ ] work so
anyways that's a separate video now
itself but yeah don't leave with money
when dr kim asked turner how she
supported herself she said that she
lived off a 500 000 inheritance from her
great-grandmother
you brought your grandma into this the
audacity
the audacity
i'm not mad at you hoenn you prob you
mind this i'm not mad at you but like i
said the same thing okay grandmother you
popped me up in heaven just chilling all
of a sudden she feel like a burn mark
come up like the devil just like i said
the same thing kind of sin did i get
involved with you
why didn't you get me in this you know i
mean she survived world war ii me my
dead right she died afterwards meanwhile
did nothing to you you know what i mean
she never even seen a smartphone god
damn you got to put mima in this like
[ __ ] that needs to lie from work
like my grandma did and then they their
grandma died she's really using her
[Music]
damn the ancestors of who and that's
crazy abba why'd you cheat
uh you know my grandfather taught me
that like a real man's worth is by how
many women he can
i'm not gonna mention my grandfather if
i get caught [ __ ] up she got a great
grandmother i can't believe you did that
can i ask ancestors
why do you think she skipped grandma
because grandma's probably in that hold
on too she's probably alive in hohen
i don't know yeah why are you
disrespecting our ancestors because she
does it for free
just because she do it don't you yeah
true all right respect on regina
turner's grandmother probably because
she was alive that's what i was going to
say that's what i said no she's like
she's alive and holy
i'm i'm happy to have my grandmother
what grandmother
you need to go out there and see
grandma's hoenn they'd be home okay my
grandma she wasn't like hoenn but she
did know how to party look at irish
catholics
they drink let me tell you all this like
your grandma's generation was a
different cloth i would say my grandma's
generation just got pregnant sooner
my grandma got knocked up at 16 then she
got married
now there's just more opportunity to
leave they were still doing the same
stuff
baby owen once started a sex podcast
he's just like man listen the fetishes
are everywhere no no it's not that it's
me being out there
it's me being out there being a bouncer
i've seen too many shits
i've seen too many things bro
i've seen too many things hey man listen
i don't know if this guy's going to get
his marriage
annulled for fraud i think he got
fleeced and he's going to have to hold
this big old l
hey man listen marriage is not a joke
especially for guys with money
take precautions all right
get your prenups done what happen
prenups don't work they do if you know
what the [ __ ] you're doing
okay
get her a lawyer get yourself a lawyer
get it done properly protect yourselves
let me get this template let me get a
template of a prenup online no i'm just
telling y'all a lot of you ladies
yeah and listen
as i tell you man the hotter they are
the odds of this happening are much more
elevated so
yeah something you went from miss
connecticut bro you know what's funny
about these magazines i guarantee you
like maxine i guarantee you
there's a contact at maxim who's in
contact with these high rich people he
contacts the person maximus like i want
to get her contact info easy peasy like
that
a lot of these like high-end spots even
whether it be playboy max and all these
things like that get these women in
contact with rich dudes
for some home
that's called a booking agent
yeah not legally though
it's booking for company so it depends
how you put it in the eyes of the law so
more like a liaison
booking agent you know what i'm saying
the guys who are really rich what they
do is they donate the money to maxim or
whatever it is whatever company okay
they're trying to just knock that
they'll be like give me give me the
contacts because i want
miss this girl from this month
for
work
yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's a weird world i grew up in a
very different world
i think i just wasn't hot enough to be
like
to have this as an option
you know
and i don't think i think all my friends
i have some pretty attractive friends
but i think they got wifed up
too early to really have this
as an option and you guys might be
wondering abba how would you know
because i happen to know somebody who
works in one of these little magazines
and they'd be telling me some stuff that
they see behind the scenes some of their
rich donors and how it works out
that's right
does it mean that all these women are
holy no sir
but does that mean that some of them are
sure your favorite instagram model
might
alright guys let me know in the comments
what how much money someone would have
to pay you to do something like that as
a guy so i feel like women
like if you were a guy because i think
most of my viewers are male
how much money would it take for you to
be like bought
could you be bought let me know in the
comments don't forget to subscribe to
the channel ring that notification bell
and i'll talk to you guys next time